two things here that concerns one is
elon musk i'm sure you know you know
what his position is with with this he's
said this for many many times he said
this in 18.
uh he fears a.i more than anybody else
does like the way he says you know you
guys are worried about this there's
nothing to be worried about worry about
ai speaking out of my team 2014 musk uh
called ai humanity biggest existential
threat
and compared it to summoning the demon
ai scientists at oxford and uc berkeley
luminaries like stephen alkin and
many of the researchers publishing
groundbreaking result agree with musk
that ai could be very dangerous
they are concerned that we're eagerly
working toward developing power powerful
air systems and we might be
we might do so under conditions that are
ripe for
dangerous mistakes as ai gets probably
much smarter than humans the relative
intelligence ratio is probably similar
to that between a person and a cat maybe
bigger i this is ilan saying this i do
think we need to be very careful about
the advancement of ai there's a very
strong concentration of ai power
especially at google deep mind and have
very high regard for larry page and
dennis hasabis but i do think there's
value to some independent oversight what
do you say about what elon's thoughts
are on artificial intelligence well i
think elon musk is a great man you know
he's invented a lot of stuff so
um and he's an amazing entrepreneur as
well he's got a ton of written
determination i think he's spot on about
quite a few things right we're open to
regulation we think regulation would be
good
if there are laws saying that for
example these data sets should only be
used for law enforcement that shouldn't
be used for you know all these other use
cases i think that would help
a lot of the general public
come to more ease around the technology
if there was you know some guidelines
and government regulation and oversight
on facial recognition technology i think
that ai has continuously surprised me on
how much better and accurate it has
gotten
my philosophy at the end of the day is
to always have a human in the loop right
we want tools to serve us and the way we
build the technology is you know when
you do the search and you find the image
you click the link you try and find the
name and then you continue your
investigation it's helping make
people who do their jobs more efficient
and better at their jobs
technology that does that
is awesome right technology that uh what
i think i get a little worried about is
things around automated decision making
right and things like that uh can you
tell me more so automated decision
making um you know could be if something
is really high um
uh
for example a system that could
you know do the identification and then
say all right automatically go arrest
that person right there's no human there
making a judgment machines and ai just
can do what humans do
on a repetitive basis in a better way
so that's why machines are really good
at like facial recognition they're
really good at searching the internet
they're good at those kind of things but
they're not good at making certain
judgments right or uh
you know human relations and things like
that so
machines are good at certain things but
humans are a lot better at still a lot
of things and as long as humans are in
charge right that
you have
a functioning government you have rule
of law all those kind of things i i see
this as a technology that just makes
humans better at what they do
and that's how i think a lot of ai
should be deployed i don't think people
want to live in a
world like skynet
no i don't think i don't think they do i
think
we like freedom uh i think the idea of
having somebody
uh watch us you know like
i don't know who we had on here
uh we had somebody on here saying the
power of having things being recorded
because you get to see like you know the
human uh what do you call it citizen
journalism yeah is one of the best
things that happened where
this
gave everybody a form of accountability
right this has become one of the most
powerful weapons where we get to see
videos and say
oh that's not cool what you just did
right there
got it anybody
with common sense can say
that was not acceptable just took place
right there right yeah okay if we don't
have this we can't judge it for
ourselves right
the concern is what you just said right
now which is what was the word use
automated decision making yeah automated
decision making where a computer can
tell us
this guy is about to commit a crime this
guy needs to be arrested
uh uh we don't want to go in that
direction you still need the human touch
where we're not just going to rely 100
solely on technology to make decisions
for us especially bigger decisions like
when you talk about the judicial process
there have been talks or like
hey can you do automated decision making
on sentencing and things like that i
don't think that's a good idea i think
there always should be a human judge
and jury and all that kind of stuff when
it comes to making decisions because
it's a human world we live in if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]